guys who doesn't love a good underdog
story in eSports as with all things it's
hard not to root for the David over the
Goliath that's why this week we're
bringing you the top 10 underdog moments
in csgo now guys when I say underdog
moments I'm not talking about clutch
plays here I'm talking about when a dark
horse team goes on an improbable
tournament run I'm talking about when
the upstarts take down the favorites as
for how we rank the list when we looked
at the obstacles in each team's way we
looked at how deep their run went and
yes we looked at their effect on csgo
history so without further [ __ ]
let's get into it with the top 10
underdog moments in csgo
teamliquid themselves put it best rarely
are the liquid boys a favorite but they
can never be ruled out kicking off this
list we have liquids iconic run at ESL
one cologne 2016 where they made history
by becoming the first North American
team to reach a major Grand Final headed
into the tournament some doubted their
chances of even making it to playoffs
but liquid never stopped believing you
want to hope for a liquid and then the
underdog chance okay we have seen
underdogs beat Navi with that said
though still very rarely that Navi lose
a full best of three series nitro his
presence knowing it long and Guardians
aware
if liquid lose this round they are in a
lot of trouble at least misleading
position and now JVM is delivering it is
2.1 more what maybe might be negative
teens who have already made history by
becoming the first ever North American
team to reach a major final but the big
question on their shoulders right now is
can they end ten years of waiting for a
North American major tentative in the
first-ever
America's only major final the boys in
blue will once again the underdogs and
it was here that sk-gaming put an end to
the dream but which do you remember the
loss or the run itself and Americans did
so well to get this from simples
immortalized heavenly play to JDM zase
liquid showed the world why one should
never count them out he's back he's
gotta rise from the ashes like the
Phoenix that he claims to be but he's
caught be open and tyloo they'll talk
not only liquid but wake up world
because the major champions have just
lost to China csgo wasn't exactly the
shooter of choice for China back in 2016
and as a result the region was never
really part of the conversation in the
world of professional csgo
coming in at number nine we have tyloo
were one of the first Chinese teams to
fully transition to the game making
their international debut at Dreamhack
Masters Malmo 2016 after an unimpressive
showing against luminosity gaming tyloo
were able to take out Team Liquid to
stay alive in the group stage fancies
gonna go he's gonna catch them off the
map slow movement speed simples down one
shot for nitro again but he's on 15 this
time he can't play the hero and it's
gone
liquid Falls the semi-finalists for
major Lulu's to tyloo in the decider
match for their group what should have
been an easy 2 o 4 LG turned into a
slugfest the decoy not a flag did
somebody flanked it ty Lou's got map one
against LG who would've thought ty loose
that complete underdogs of this
tournament just taking the first map and
the best of three
I can't luminosity gaming here tyloo
showed they didn't just come to play
they came to win going all the way to
eliminate LG from the tournament and
that's it the major champions be knocked
out by one of the biggest underdogs of
this tournament no one has to be
expected him to even get out the group
stages better knows me knocking these
guys out that's absolutely nuts like
mind-blowing
everything about this match was going
the way of LG the desk set the same
there's no way we could have predicted
it and despite losing in the first round
of the playoffs
tyloo put China on the map and shocked
the world with one of the biggest upsets
in cs:go history and mSL's a follow what
up they got him flash but he's still
getting the kills looking with a pistol
a little bit more than there it is
triple kill team dignitas may have been
contenders but were certainly not
favourites to win
epicentre 2016 still they held their own
in the round-robin group stage tying all
three matches to make it out over ni P V
around differential for our number eight
spot we have Dignitas 'as epic run in
Moscow at epicenter after dropping the
first map to a struggling fnatic digs
playoff run looked faded to end right
there and then fnatic amping it and
watching exactly where you're coming
from no hope at all fitting the tops at
the end but the Danish team was able to
turn things around
moving on to take out Navi and three
maps to meet virtus Pro in the grand
final I I don't want to call it early
but I feel like this crowd is gonna be
on VP sign some low we're seeing a lot
of versus Pro signs dig came back after
being down all in one putting a stop to
a then surging polish plow in dominating
fashion the biggest victory late for
this team amazing play needless to say
it was a result and a run that no one
could have expected
performance for them Stewie again people
have been saying if if they're building
the sewers this Shannon look at this is
he goes back Brazilians are some of the
most passionate fans you'll find in all
of cs:go
so when the ESL pro league season for
finals took place in Sao Paulo it felt
like SK gaming were destined to take the
title
and despite topping the na league ladder
c9 were certainly not the team anyone
predicted to challenge them at number 7
the boys from na take on an esky gaming
backed by the entire arena after
dropping the first map in a closed over
time it seemed like choke 9 all over
again
but c9 were able to defy the crowd and
in the next two maps these past SK on
their home turf turning the venue into a
library
normally the crowd erupts when a team
wins a tournament that is quite a hollow
victory there considering the atmosphere
besting SK on home soil there's no
sweeter a victory than that
the shadow though does have a real
opportunity hey toaster quick reload
just about has time for that as Eve
comes both of MIB focus on de how does
he get that one ninjas in pyjamas may
have always been a household name and
csgo but few outside of the CIS region
had ever heard of Vega squadron so for
our number six spot when these two teams
squared up at the e league major Atlanta
2017 qualifier on a map the ninjas were
known to perform on Vegas chances were
quite simply written off and one of the
maps was cashed that was the best map
that became known but a CIS team
upsetting n IP wasn't unheard of some
even joked that n IP should be worried
about facing Vega and they were right
and it is looking worse and was it just
exists now against the five players for
Vega squadron and it's all over Vega
squadron will eliminate n IP four of the
ni p players had been on every single
match in the history of Counter Strike
in the end while Vega didn't make it to
the major their win on cash meant that
for the first time in csgo history an IP
would not be attending a major
championship
for steal kits for steal who's the one
with 1 hp getting closer to Danny Boy
their birthdays define committee backs
away kids we picked up fight won't sit
but Susie's gonna sit on top of it this
will be the round
I am NOT going to give up before I win a
[ __ ] major these words from
veteran in-game leader Zeus would turn
out to be prophetic a year after he
tweeted them with an unlikely team
backing him gambit eSports it was at the
pgl major Krakow 2017 that the
Cinderella story would take shape for
our fifth spot on this list no one
expected this CIS roster to contend for
a major championship let alone go the
distance and win one it was Zeus and
gambit versus the world
gambits round-robin score was impressive
but it was in the semis where they faced
Astralis in the hardest match of their
careers very much looking forward to
this one this is the biggest test maybe
for gambit of their career eight
dangerous positions to vice knows to
look out for it misses
the grand final saw underdog against
underdog with the unexpected matchup of
gambit against immortals but it is Zeus
dosha Hobbit a dren and Moe who would
triumph good I just want to say that
just believe your dream follow your
dream and just work a lot thank you guys
thank you some teams have that special
place where no matter how badly they're
doing elsewhere they just always seem to
step up and perform for ninjas in
pyjamas that place is Auckland and for
our fourth spot on the list we have a
serious case of nip magic towards the
end of 2016 and eyepiece performance was
questionable sk-gaming on the other hand
were at the top of the csgo world but
even after going down 16 for in the
first map of the IEM grand final against
the Brazilians the ninjas pulled through
in spectacular fashion 2017 was another
year of lackluster performances for ni P
in spite of that the Swedes managed to
find their way back to the grand final
at IEM Auckland 2017 was the finals
watched here on this very stage
the semi-finals this year and the
champions will return on IP 60 11 to 1
over s case back to the finals of IEM
the defending champions have done at
what a performance at in a final that
gave us all a sense of deja vu n IP
found themselves in an unfavorable
matchup against another top team faze
clan after an absolute marathon of a
series ninjas in pyjamas successfully
defended their Oakland title making them
unlikely but lovable two-time champs on
stage again with threat on board and
then CH man to carry the mighty
ni P returning to taking the world on in
counter-strike they fell from grace but
they do return and they return at full
force
hello comes once again the first base is
attorneys gonna hit the ground there's
cold
called the same luminosity with your
play unthinkable scenes there on the
beer profits they needed a huge play
without something I'm never gonna see
ever again
although the now decorated Brazilian
core of fallen cold Zahra and fur is one
of the most successful in counter-strike
history it wasn't always so there was a
time when the legends had to prove
themselves and that's exactly what they
did in our number three entry
luminosity gaming were on the rise at
the start of 2016 and people were
starting to notice Brazilian CS but in
the past the ukrainian squad had often
come out on top so when the boys from
Brazil faced off against the
back-to-back major finalists
Navid seemed destined to finally win
their first major title at MLG Columbus
and deny LG with wins over virtus Pro
and Team Liquid to reach the final many
thought that that would be the end of
their tail but after a close overtime on
their mat pickup Mirage LG managed to
edge out the win
it was then on na vi's map pic of
overpass that the Brazilians would truly
show their dominance gali in busses taco
they may just be destined to fade finish
throwing off the team winning that fast
championship luminosity made history by
becoming the first non-european major
champions and after a rebrand shortly
after they would go on to win the next
csgo major establishing an era of
Brazilian dominance everyone said we
couldn't do it everyone said we didn't
have the talent and we did it way
different than everyone else in the
world
that's how I want us to do remember oh
it's six they're trailing and it's
pistols here
that spray transfer so sick
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
the E League season two Grand Final
which was truly a David versus Goliath
scenario optic versus Astralis nobody
believed that optic would even make it
to the final even after taking down
fnatic to qualify for the playoffs the
NA team was frankly a non-factor
face is gonna be the up to tonight
personally I think we should be up to
everyday in a week I think the
semi-final it could be easier for us a
win over fellow underdogs mousesports
was within reason defeating phase claim
could have been a fluke secure the spot
over their longtime rivals phase plan
for the grand finals up against a straw
Lusa danish team it's happening but
against astralis surely optic had no
chance right wrong after falling to the
danes on train rush Neff and the rest of
the NA squad shocked the csgo world and
they did the impossible and beat the
future major champions over the next two
maps
I have just blown away a mixed group and
I'm really determined that as well the
support will see the whole wanted right
in front sheering the whole way through
this is a Cinderella story like we've
always never seen it before I still
can't believe this one can anyone
picking up the torch that liquid left
behind cloud nine made it to the eleague
Boston major Grand Finals and claimed a
championship for North America on home
soil the first ever and first on our
list of cs:go underdog moments
they run the favorites they were the
underdogs they were a heavy on the throw
but they did it for North America don't
wanna buy a job after immediately going
down Owen - in the new legend stage
cloud9 had to win three consecutive
matches to keep their major dreams alive
squeezing into the playoffs the NA team
made their way through to the grand
final with wins over French super team
g2 eSports and Brazilian rivals SK
gaming final boss faze clan awaited them
it's hard to exaggerate just how
incredibly favored phase was in this
matchup but cloud nines fans never
stopped believing and North America's
Heroes would not let their story and
they're even after a close two feet on
Mirage c9 defied the choke nine curse
and caught up by winning overpass taking
it to a deciding map of inferno
every single fan of NACS should know
what happened next
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
patiently
the pushup
[Music]
I'm not crying you're crying stop well
guys that's our list now look if you do
disagree with it and you decide to post
a well-written well-thought-out
grammatically correct argument in the
comment section while you're the real
underdog thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button